Donald Trump was at Buckingham Palace
for a NATO reception and everyone's
talking about Princess Anne's reaction
as he greeted Queen Elizabeth
the princess is trending right now yes
I'll take a look at Donald and Melania
saying hi to the Queen here we go
through the second here there's Camilla
mm-hmm little chitchat yeah then they're
gonna see the princess and just kind of
around the corner there so the Queen
looks over seems she says something to
the tan off the side and just shrugs
like what do you want for me just like
they just leave and over there so yeah
people are having a lot of fun with this
on Twitter so British glamour tweeted
Princess Anne's snubbing Donald Trump
has made her officially our favorite
memorable member of the royal family
shrugs Mashable said Princess Anne
shrugging when the Queen asked sort of
grief Trump to the national mood the
editor-in-chief of royal central tweeted
princess and once fought off an armed
kidnapper she knows how to handle
unstable people and the new European
said Princess Anne wins over fans after
stuffing Donald Trump now after that
moment and was part of another viral
moment uh-huh so after her said she
knows how to make him that's coming so
she chatted with Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau French president Emmanuel
macron and British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson and they all seemed to be
getting together to be like can you
believe this guy
whoa
this'll Trump already said he saw that
clipping something Trudeau is two-faced
you go yeah yeah we heard all about that
this morning
I'm you know get togethers fancy
get-togethers at best can be very
awkward right let alone when your world
leaders and the new watching you
I think the rally with the Trudeau thing
like it goes to both Trump supporters
and haters yeah like Trump supporters
are gonna love that
look you know he's the rebel like other
leaders don't like them and then Trump
haters are gonna be saying like look
look at how we're looked on the world
stage
yeah I will sweep up with that Princess
Anne moment do you think she's actually
like shrugging that she doesn't want to
meet Trump or she's just like what am I
supposed to be over there yeah I didn't
like I think it's more like she doesn't
know we're like what like what do you
want me to do like I don't think it's
necessary like I don't want I don't
think it's I don't want to come meet
Trump it strikes me as more like am I
supposed to come over there like she's
confused like it's first you know to
kind of like me into it and make like
fun tweets about it but honestly even
from Washington like I can't tell what
yeah I really know what you're supposed
to do know it says Princess Anne is the
queen of shade I'm here for it and it's
epic
Paul says leaders of all human Trump and
ridicule go together Valeska says
Princess Anne is waiting for the orange
blob to move on Wolfson wanna be there
be in the way